Hello.
Hey, what's going on? Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast. Dan,
I'm just checking in on you. Okay,
so you know your week's going.
How are you guys doing?
I am in a great mode.
I'm in an awesome mood. Ah, you in a
bad mood. You driving in your car there,
you stuck in traffic.
Is this some Dosha in front of you
not doing what you want them to do?
Oh, you haven't? Little dictated thoughts.
Thinking about what you
would do if you are in power,
what you would do with this person,
what rule you would implement. You know,
it's gotta be awesome being a dictator,
you know what I mean?
How much fun is it on the 4th
of July to shoot off fireworks?
Can you imagine how much fun that
fatty over North Korea's haven't?
You know how hard did they fucking laugh
when they shot that one over Japan?
I mean, Jesus Christ, we had a fuck dude.
Everybody had to go to bed after that.
Then he's just laying in bed,
so fucking amped up like a kid.
Believe we just did tell me.
I know it's crazy.
We just freaked out a whole country.
Okay. Calling each other up,
dude. The whole world's
talking about us, man.
What a fucking lunatic.
What if there was a malfunction
on that fucking thing in it?
Any do you just landed? That
guy is, I'm telling you man,
he's got to lay off the fucking sweet.
All that sugar is just cs.
There's not fucking,
it's not doing them good.
He's not making sound decisions.
Thank God we have such a
level headed guy on our side.
Oh my God.
You know,
watching the dead zone was always scary.
Watching the Martin Sheen
character get into power,
but I think to go back and watch it now
is going to be just picture and Donald
Trump go on.
The birds are away gentlemen and doing
that little thing he does where he puts
his index finger and his thumb together
and this other three fingers are in the
air.
The birds of the way,
the greatest birds ever. Um, yeah.
Jesus Christ.
All this fucking end the day shit
talking about these goddamn tornadoes one
after another. You know, like some
battle royal of fucking weather.
I did Rogan show last night.
There's nothing worst than hanging out
with somebody who's fucking informed.
He starts Salmat instinct was
forming out over the Atlantic.
They'd never seen anything like this.
This is the size of fucking Florida.
Hey Bill,
how much time do you want to do tonight?
I was in a fucking panic. He was like
laughing at me. Go look at Bill's face.
Look at Bill's face. It's like, Joe, what
look am I supposed to have on my face?
When you basically said,
you know everything,
you had everything but Jesus fucking
crowd surfing in on that fucking thing.
Not to mention, I'm going to miss
ship in Alabama this weekend. Okay,
Mississippi, Alabama. The harder the FCC,
I'm gonna tell you something right now
is a fucking northern white boy. Yanky.
I fucking love Mississippi and Alabama.
I love that whole fucking structure.
The south,
how they all shit on each other and
then it's somehow lands in Louisiana.
Louisiana's lap, right? You're in Georgia
and all they do is make fun, Alabama,
right? Alabama's like, Fuck Georgia. Hey,
at least we're not Mississippi
and Mississippi. So like, go,
what the fuck do you want from us?
Ah, why don't you go to Shreveport?
Tell me how you fucking enjoy that.
What's going on there?
It's free there and I couldn't no
catfish. Um, I love it down there.
Granted I'm fucking white. You don't even
have to Klan started marching, you know,
and I got all fucking nervous. I could
fake my way through it. You know,
give him a nod.
You don't slip into a store real quick.
Um, anyways, I don't know if I
mentioned this the other day. Um,
I started playing catch again. You know,
something I used to do as a kid. Good,
clean, fun. You just need a glove of
ball in a friend, maybe a baseball kid,
baseball kid baseball. He had. Um,
and it's just been a good time.
This is how old I am.
I did 45 minutes a catio and
I can say I didn't stretch.
I thought I stretched and I went out there
and a old Billy fucking old face does
not have the range of motion
he used to have. And, um,
my buddy through the ball and it bounced
in front of me and it just sorta was
skidding along the ground and I bent
down to get it and anticipating it was
going to hop on.
I don't know what I was doing or I just
didn't get down far enough and went
right by my glove and hit right
and my left ghost white calf.
And um,
it only hurt as much as it
should of heard like a baseball.
However fast it was traveling
and he hit the ground,
it's slowed down a little bit me then.
Nice sound against my alabaster shit.
Right then I thought I was fine
and within like three throws,
my calf just fucking tightened up.
Like you couldn't believe.
And for like the last three days,
it's felt like it's on fire.
Right?
Like if you thought of my,
like if they were going to
do a documentary on my calf,
they would go to van Halen one and they
would take that clip from David Lee Roth
singing, I'm on fire. Um,
it's been fucking killing me.
So, uh, I got to have a, I don't know,
I'm going to have somebody
fucking work it out, but, uh,
my buddy gave me this shit.
This is a free advertisement.
This is how fucking good these guys are.
It's called a aren't a care gel.
They ever heard of this stuff. It's,
it's homeopathic.
What'd you call me?
Homeopathic medicine aren't a care,
it's for muscle pain and stiffness.
Swelling from injuries and bruising.
I get pain relief. This shit, I'm
telling you, it's fucking magic.
I put this stuff on, I felt like
I was bionic, you know, like,
like in that you could just fix
me like a machine. One of those,
one of those fucking Moonraker movies,
blade runner, whatever the fuck it is.
Like they would just open my cabinet and
it looked like the inside of a fucking
mix. I just felt like that they just, that
thing just soldered a couple of wires,
wires to get. I mean, it
didn't cure me. I mean,
I definitely feel like now I just feel
like I got hit with a golf ball rather
than a baseball.
MMM.
You know, at the end of a drive,
I'm not saying right off the tee,
let's not get crazy here. Okay,
let's not get crazy. So anyways,
that's the free thing.
I'll tell you right now,
if you fucking ever do something before
you go to a masseuse and haven't fucking
unglue your muscles and get all
that Schmutz out of there is my,
a person says, ah, Arna Care Gel a.
R.
N.
I Care Arnie care like Arnold Palmer,
except it's I a r.
N. I. L. I. A. R. N. I. E. Right?
Yeah. Why don't you confuse to people?
So he goes, I had to do some free massage
because I lost another advertiser.
I can't believe it. I put my fucking
heart and soul into these fucking reads.
You know, I could go monotone.
I can just read what they wrote.
Okay.
I could just go with it. But you're
not going to listen. And I know this
show must go on even if I'm
reading fucking advertising.
But those fucking console over there,
the most those people,
that was a one and done.
Yeah.
How dare you bring up hand jobs that
at the end of the massage rates,
what the fuck are you talking about?
That's a huge part of your industry.
Either you're doing it, oh,
you're not doing it
the fuck.
It's like your year in food.
You're selling some sort of food.
Now bring up trans fat,
like that's not a big fucking issue.
That is a hot button issue.
That dead is dead.
That needs to be brought up in front
of Congress. When I, I stand by that.
If you could legalize
weed at a state level,
you should be able to legalize a
hand job at the state level. Okay.
Now if the feds come in and she's got
your Dick in her hand, you're Ron,
you're wrong. All right. You're
on your fucking own. You Joe.
Pesci in good fellas out.
No. Right. That's it.
Yeah,
that's it. All right ladies.
It does it mean anything to us.
It doesn't mean anything.
If you ever saw the look on the woman's
face when she's doing it, I mean,
I swear to God.
Okay.
I swear to God, like it's just like
she's, she, I don't know what she did.
Thinking of fucking zillion other things,
which is probably usually where you
got this part of your safe place,
you know when you're fucking
employed in the sex industry. Um,
I don't know what the fuck to
tell you. I know it's tight. So,
because I brought that up, which was
funny enough to make people listen,
they walked away from all the fucking
massages that my listeners would have got.
Okay.
Now I'm not going to lie to a third
of them would have been expecting
some sort of a hand release at the end
of it. So maybe, maybe that's okay.
I'll take that. Okay. I will. I will
take that part of it. All right.
What I'm getting tired of these deeds,
deed, the blue aprons, the nature boxes,
you know,
they're all good when the sun's out
and the second they see a little bit of
rough water.
Okay.
What do they do? They fucking
pull up stakes. It was
fucking phony bastards. Okay.
And they take their aprons and they're
fucking twats and they go to somebody
else's podcast. And I'll tell you
right now, I've had enough of it.
My,
my gosh darn just over here.
Okay.
To try and put a little bit of
money in your pocket. You know,
how many people do you think
at that fucking massage place?
I've actually gone to a massage parlor
and gotten fucking jerked off. How many,
you know what I mean? Fucking out. She's
done it. Don't get me fucking start.
You know, I got in the, Oh my
dogs back in town called Clio.
He's back in town. I just saw
her, she fucking freaked out.
We had a nice little battle royal.
I took over this awesome fucking hike.
Love that God damn dog. And I love
that. She's got a great family now.
Family Big East. And uh, she
put it on a little bit awake.
He's new people there. They're raw.
They're treating her right. Um,
but she looked awesome and, uh, same
old dog dragging me down the street,
all frigging excited and that
type of stuff. So, uh, it's out.
It all worked out nice,
happy in,
and she's got a little more white
whiskers around her muzzle, you know,
becoming very distinguished and stately.
These last couple of a in
the last, I don't know, it
gave away almost a year ago.
It's fucking unbelievable. Nine months
ago, 10 months ago, nine months ago,
nine months ago. Um, so it was great
to see you and everything. So, uh,
she's in town for like 10 days.
I'm leaving for a couple of days,
but that's what I do when she comes to
town. It take for a hike every morning.
It's kind of been working out. I get to
see her every couple of months, you know,
she's not around where she can eat
my baby or attack somebody else,
so she'll never get put down and I
won't have to deal with an unbelievable
amount of guilt. And she's got a
great house and she's, you know,
she's fattened up. It's fucking perfect.
I love it. She's not fat people.
I'm just saying she is
living a good life of energy.
Still a ball of muscle though.
Good Lord. That's a strong dog.
Okay.
Um, I still miss the hell out of her,
but I definitely made the right decision.
So anyways, um, what's going on
tonight? Oh, the Patriots yet that,
that dad, Buddha, Buddha,
good to do. Good to
ignore your fucking wife.
Football season is back bay.
Ignore the arcade.
Sorry. Just blow it. Years. Ignore the
hurricanes. Ignore all fatty up there.
Fucking doesn't it fucking guy in
North Korea. They look like he,
he's a same shape as like curly from
the fucking three stooges. You know,
I'd love to see me. They just reshot
the old football sketch. You know?
Can somebody please do that just for the
sort of Photoshop and do in that thing.
Does that run an employee singer?
All Rah Rah doing that whole thing.
Just put his head on Curley's
fucking body. It's what he's,
he's Kim Jong Howard.
Uh, how many times would I be put
to death in that fucking country?
I can't even fucking imagine.
I can't even imagine. You know,
you got to go out swinging. You got to
go out like a fucking, you know, Gino,
I'm not, I, you know, sit
down was a fucking brutal guy.
But did you see how that guy went out?
He was standing there.
He's just staring them all in the eye.
They put the rope around his neck.
He's still talking shit. Yeah, go
fuck yourself. Go Fuck Yourself.
You know it's fucking any people always
talk about, dude, when you were in Philly,
how did you handle? They're fucked, Dan.
We'll know when we would sit down handled.
He was talking Shit, right? Until
they fucking Yank that rope. Oh,
that lever or whatever. I would've
been crying like a little girl. Go on.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'll sweep the streets.
That's how I would have gone out,
gone into the next world and God
would have just been looking at me,
shaking his head, you know, of all
the awful fucking things you did.
I think you're bitchy way you left
was the worst. Get Out of my sight.
And then they just pushes the
button and go down to health.
I go down a hill and a burn forever.
And that's a good fucking thing to bring
up when you got two gigs coming up,
Mississippi and Alabama, I'm gonna
tell you, go down my CVL Bam.
Lynn's mother fuckers ain't got
computers yet. They ain't got computers.
But I'll tell you, they still eat.
They'll still leading. I don't tell you.
Give him some clothes line and they'll
catch catfish. He and dry your overalls,
mother fuckers.
They can live off the land.
You know, if, um, what Rogan was
telling me was even remotely true,
him and Jimmy Dora are the
two most informed fucking
comedians I know as far as
they actually pay attention to shit.
Somebody says some shit.
And rather than just taking it as truth,
they actually will fucking research it.
They'll have guests on their show. I
cannot recommend their podcasts. And, uh,
his bar Joe's podcast and uh,
um,
Jimmy doors youtube show highly enough.
And you don't always have
to fucking agree with them.
But I'm telling you right now,
I want to tell you something right now.
If you fucking watch and see it.
And if you're watching Fox News and Shit,
I mean that's, you know, those
people. Okay, I'm going to, you know,
no offense to other comedians,
but they're definitely more well
spoken than a lot of us. But you know,
I'm just saying there is
a whole, uh, you know,
just look at how they read the
ads on those channels and then,
you know exactly like that.
They're, they're, they're,
they're stuck between the
lines. May, I don't know what
I'm talking about them. Um,
uh, fuck that reminded me of something now
I just forgot it. What the hell was it?
Something I wanted to talk about.
Not News,
not be in between the lines
a fucking, it's over. Um,
so anyways, I am going to, uh, one of my
favorite things and I don't have a lot of,
I don't have any favorite things in
Mississippi yet cause I've only been there
one time,
two times.
One time I was driving up to the airport
after I watched the Patriots beat the
rams and the super bowl and I just
couldn't get a flight into fucking New
Orleans. So we drove, we flew in and out
of fucking, uh, what does it, Baton Rouge,
Mississippi. I'm kidding.
Um, Jackson, Jackson,
Mississippi. And um, and then I
did a gig there a few years ago.
Um, so, ah, I don't know a
lot about it, but Alabama,
Alabama. I'll tell you something. What
I love about Alabama, I loved the, uh,
first of all, the fucking, I'm going to
the Alabama game, by the way, on Saturday.
It's an afternoon game against mighty,
Mighty Fresno state.
They could surprise some people.
Um, so I'm going to go there.
I'm not going to be a cunt
in root against Alabama.
I really don't hate the crimson tide.
It's just that they are the fucking,
the Yankees or the Patriots. So, you know,
they're the ones that always fucking,
you know, uh, winning, right?
So, uh, we'll Yankees, you know,
they, they want enough, even
though they haven't won since 2009,
so there's still the fucking Yankee. So
sitting on 27, you know what I mean? Um,
okay.
I just couldn't become a college fan
and jump on their bandwagon. Like,
if I was watching the NFL, I would
fucking root against the Patriots to,
that's what you do. If you, if you just
what you do, it's what you do, you know,
just jump on the fucking big bandwagon.
I'm like Roger Clemens,
when he joined the Yankees after
they'd already one fucking three. Um,
okay.
I would say Yah.
Yeah,
yeah. That's, that's how, that's why I
root against them. So when I go there,
I'm not going to be a cop.
I'm going to root for Alabama.
But there is a major part of me that
wants to bet Fresno state and just start
the game up. Like, you
know, it's 57 to nothing,
but you know what it is.
Nick Saban has an intensity
slash anchor slash in ability.
I'm telling you to drown a puppy that I,
I just know that even as second string,
it's just going to keep, you know,
running up the points because they
don't want to deal with it and practice,
you know,
that they didn't score another fucking
30 points against Fresno's number one,
I don't know anything about Fresno state.
I'm not trying to disrespect Fresno.
Okay.
Now, if you're like me and you watch any
sort of basic cable stuff about gangs or
prisons or anything, they
always, it's a, you know,
the second they start one of those shows,
you can literally turn over an hour.
Glass is sand and it's not getting me to
get halfway through before they end up
in Fresno. And then there's
always that guy, you know,
with the Bandana all the way up to
under resides Bandana on his head.
And then the dark sunglasses,
they have his voice, altered
names. Look, girl, birth,
normal burden of care.
Pretty aware of the more vocal booth.
We'll go for the real mobile. You can't
understand a word they're saying, right?
Not because my urge would cove. Um,
so I'm not trying to fuck with Fresno.
All right?
Everybody knows that fucking stretch
between La and San Francisco.
You don't know what the
fuck goes on out there,
Charlie Manson lives somewhere up there.
All right. There's a nice national park.
There's a bunch of people growing
food. But other than that, you know,
I don't know what goes on
other than it's really hot.
And a lot of people grew up career board
from Europe. So I don't have any fun,
not trying to fucking shit on Fresno.
Okay.
I'm just a praise pasty freckled guy
trying to go to a football game. So I'm,
I'm working with del Rey
and fucking Joe Bart,
nick the Rosebowl tailgate legend and a,
we're doing a Gig at some casino in a
missed ship and then were in Alabama.
And when I go to Alabama,
I got a place that I liked to eat every
time I go there. First Time I went there,
a fan came. Remember how I found out
by buying gold, their bug type saws.
Barbecue started stands
for smart ass Wilson's.
I always go there.
They have a Manet's based barbecue sauce.
Swear to God. It's white. You're like,
there's no way that's going to taste good.
You eat it. You're like, Jesus,
that's fucking delicious.
Jesus Christ. Is that delicious?
So, um, that's a good time.
I'm actually thinking of
coming back again next year.
I'm going to do quick kick here and
then I think I'm going to come back next
year,
do a little bit of a bigger show and
next year I'm going to go to Talladega.
I went to Daytona 500 I'm going to go
Talladega next. I got to go to that man.
I used to always watch that with
hair game, you know, scold that car.
Cale Yarborough I'm fucking uh,
what's his fade? Rusty Wallace.
Daryl Hall trip.
Who else was fucking running back then?
Richard Petty was winding down.
I told you that.
I used to buy all the fucking model cars.
I build them and put the
stickers on them and shit.
I used to always skip the engine because
they just wanted to get to the fucking
car part and I wouldn't let it dry
and it wouldn't let the paint dry.
I was just too fucking,
they always came out like shit.
There was glue all over the place because
I was just too impatient, you know?
I wish I could buy one of those models
again and actually just take the time to
see if I could do it right.
Like the people who really did it right,
they would paint all the parts before
they even took it off that plastic grid
and they would let it dry for like a day.
And then they would just slowly put
the whole fucking thing together.
And it was a fucking work of that. I
would never do that. I was all, you know,
you know as the worst was
when you remembered the
decals and he'd soak them in
the warm water, then they'd all start
coming off and you were like fuck.
And they would roll up and you,
they all look like shit and they'd be
put on lead like an angle, you know?
Then he, then he had like
the older guys, right?
And they had a little thing like
pair of tweezers. All right.
They'd have a pair of tweezers
and that little fucking, you know,
judo jeweler glasses on and they
put it on there. Look, unbelievable.
And I always wish I had the
patience to do that. And I don't.
And that's why standup comedy spend the
only thing that was ever good at this
because it is just going up there
and just fucking letting you add go.
And I kind of learned something this week
within in my a frustrating way trying
to learn drums and it's just like to do,
you have to fucking sit down and
if you want to learn something,
you have to take a big breath,
you have to relax and you
have to start really slow.
And I've known this for fucking years,
I've seen everybody talk about it.
Some of the most monster players ever
talk about how slow they start a new idea.
But the whole thing is,
you know with all this information
on the Internet you can be like,
well what bpm is,
is this song?
It's 115 and then you just think
[inaudible] going to get it at 10 feet.
And so you start playing it like 95 when
you should be like 65 so that's my new
shit.
I got to fucking relax.
I got to pick like one or two things
and just stick with that for awhile.
Just like how you would with the model,
right? Just leave those pieces on there.
Paint the fucking thing and walk away.
Just let it dry. So, um, anyways,
I know I'm a fucking mess here. I'm all
over. I'm all over the Goddamn map. Uh,
22 minutes of fucking talking shit. All
right, we got six reads here. People,
you know,
these fucking reads like these,
these advertises is becoming
like a special forces, you know,
or a fucking some sort of military
operation here. It's like, you know,
most of you will not be
coming back. All right. Um,
private pile infantry. You made it
all right. Draft kings, everybody.
Oh,
is this the perfect read for tonight or
what fantasy football season is finally
fought Guinea
and there's no better way to,
to get closer to the game you love with
draft kings one week fantasy fucking
football draft kings is hosting a $100,000
50 grand after tax has contest this
Sunday. That is totally free.
Free, free, free to enter.
And if you draft the perfect lineup,
you can win $1 billion.
In other words,
the odds that you're doing
that as fucking, you know,
I dunno what it's pretty
fucking difficult.
It's the odds of them have actually taken
your junk and make it into a perfect
pussy. You know, we're
not there yet. Okay?
But it doesn't stop these brave fucking
people from still trying with draft
kings.
There are many ways to play choose between
public contexts with big cash prizes
or private context tests where you can
compete against a group of your friends.
Draftkings also has a beginner and
casual content contests where you can,
where you'll play against people.
I have to get glasses. Well,
you'll play against people of a
similar skill level. Everybody gets,
the best part is you get to draft a new
team each week without any commitment.
Where is this going? Nowhere, bitch.
So to get draft kings.com
now and use Promo Code Bar,
I use program Promo Code bird to play
in the draft kings free contest with
$100,000 in total prizes this Sunday.
And if you draft the perfect lineup,
you can win $1 billion,
$1 billion. Do you realize that? What
that is? Do you have an uh, that's,
that's enough to buy? Like, I dunno.
I would say like $706 million man.
You can make 700 Steve Austin's and still
have some money leftover to put on a
gift certificate. A use my promo code
burr to play for free this Sunday.
That's Promo Code burpee.
You are are@draftkings.com
eligibility restrictions apply.
See draft kings.com for details.
Eligibility restriction.
That means their own employees probably
can't play, I would think. All right.
Oh Shit. Look all snap.
Snapvault. Who's back? Oh Club.
Look in good.
Doesn't have to cost a fortune.
Fan Club is revolutionizing the
way men shop at five Oh Geez.
I've never had found a thing that says
their name more than these people.
They found a way to make great looking
clothes affordable for everyone who
also understands that your
time is extremely valuable.
Why wasted at the mall or wandering
around in the stores each month?
They send you a curated but everybody
cure rates now curated box of two to three
items that are hand picked from the
finest vine of short trees to match the
current season and your style.
What's their name again?
Partners with cutting
edge designers and brands,
so you'll get the same quality as
top designer clothes for way less.
They've been helping men with fashion
for over 15 years and shipped to over
$100,000 100,000 men every month.
Chris Paul and Mark Walberg Cues five
o club and five pho is featured in Gq,
vice and instyle among other publications.
They know what they're doing,
so if you don't, that's okay. Why?
Because Oh club will help you build
your wardrobe one month at a time.
Jesus Christ. How many more times
they're going to say their name.
You get $120 worth of
clothes for just $60 a month.
You can pause or cancel anytime, no
commitments. I said, no, we're a bitch.
And as a fan folk club member,
five four club baby member,
you'll also receive up to 50% off items
in their online shop and access to
exclusive members only,
not the jacket items.
Free shipping and size exchanges go to
okay.
Oh club a.com right now and enter Promo
Code Burr and they'll give you 50% off
your first month's package,
plus a free pair of sunglasses.
Everything is so much crisper and clearer.
That's 50% off your first
package. Ed. Five four clubs,
spelled F as in Fab.
I as an Av,
v e fo o.
You are the number's five
four club.com C L U b.com.
Promo Code [inaudible] five four club.com
Promo Code [inaudible]. That's it.
All right. Oh, lift everybody. Oh Jesus
Christ. Look who's back. It's Lyft.
You don't want to lift.
Knows,
they know that their drivers
are what keeps them moving.
Well that's what the fuck you do.
Okay.
Do you know what Koch knows
if you're thirsty. Uh,
so they do everything they could do to
make sure their drivers are happy on
every trip.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that
believes in treating its people better.
Lift believes that being a ride share
driver should be fun if you're having a
good time.
So are their passengers.
If you're choosing a ride
sharing company to drive for,
go with the company
that treats you better.
Lift lift was the first
to offer in APP tipping.
When you drive for Lyft,
you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers get paid over $200 million in
tips. Since the feature was introduced,
express pay lets drivers get paid
almost instantly instead of four weeks.
Lyft has even taken the
guesswork out of pickups.
The new amp amp device uses isn't that
APP color coding to help passengers find
their drivers. You can earn hundreds
of dollars a week plus tips. One,
earn more money, drive more. It's never
been easier to give yourself a raise.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers mean happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out
of 10 left writers, uh,
get a perfect five star rating.
So joined the ride sharing company that
believes in treating his people better.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird
today and you'll get a $500 new driver
bonus.
That's lyft.com/ [inaudible] dot com
slash bird limited time only terms apply.
Is that the new thing?
You say you fucking name 50 time.
Oh,
this is the classic. This is the
stairway to heaven of my advertising.
Look who's back.
It's old zip.
Talk about the challenge of finding
great talent and or the importance of
finding great talent to a successful
business. I'll tell you right now,
finding town is easy, but to find
great talent wall, that's really hard,
especially if you want to be
successful in business. Um, Bill Burn,
I approve this message.
How Zip?
It's different with Ziprecruiter
on you can post your job to 100
plus job sites with just one click.
It's so easy.
Then their powerful technology weight
efficiently matches the right people to
your job better than anyone else.
That's why zip
is different. Unlike other job sites. Sip.
Yeah.
Group doesn't depend on candidates finding
you. It finds, it finds them. In fact,
80% of employers who post
a job on ZipRecruiter get
a quality candidate through
the site within one day. No more juggling
emails or calls to your fucking office.
Simply screen rate and manage
candidates in wall in one place with
Ziprecruiter's.
Easy to use dashboard.
Find out today why zip?
Okay.
It has been used by businesses of all
sizes to find the most qualified job
candidates and immediate results,
and right now my listeners plus any other
fucking podcast they advertise on can
post jobs on Ziprecruiter for free.
That's right free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/bar that's
ziprecruiter.com/part one more time to
try to try it for free.
Go to zip.com/burp all right,
upside upside.com boy,
you turn me inside. I
am. Go Fuck Yourself.
There's a better way for you to buy
business travel. It's called up side down.
Nope. Upside dot calm. You turned me.
Somebody finally told me how to sing,
that every time you buy a trip on upside
upside.com get turned on me.
You'll save your company a ton of money
and they give you an Amazon gift card
worth hundreds of dollars.
Upsides able to do this
because they bundle your
flights and hotels together for
one low price bundling prices saves money.
It's like having a threesome.
It's saves condom. What are
you, does that still faith?
It is the me.
If you're a frequent business travel,
your company saves a ton of money and
you could get thousands a year and gift
cards just for buying your air and
hotel together@upside.com plus,
you'll still get all your miles if
you're shopping for business travel.
You'd be crazy not to check out upside.com
it takes just three minutes to see
how much you can save by buying your
flights and hotels together for one low
price.
And right now when you use my neighbor,
you're guaranteed to get at
least a $100 Amazon gift card.
Your your your first trip. That's
my name. Burb, B, u, r. R. Uh,
to get
at least a $100 Amazon Gift Card for free.
Save big on travel and get
a big gift card every trip.
Evidently I love upside.com boy,
you turn me upside.com you're
turning me minimum purchase required.
See Site for complete details. Um, hey,
you know what I watched the other day,
I watched an episode of Tj fucking hookah.
The,
I will tell you this right now,
the funniest running you will ever see
in your life by William Shatner and his
fucking partner.
All they do is their constant.
They always have like a fucking wide
shot and they show TJ hooker running like
he runs for like six seconds every
shot. It's like, why? I would,
you know what it is,
is they had it,
they had to fucking do an
hours 22 or I think it would,
a full season was back then were like
22 episodes of an hour long show.
That's 22 hours of television.
Well, actually with the, uh,
with the commercials, eight
minutes per half hour, 44 minutes,
they had to wait 44 minutes
of fucking Shit Times 22.
I mean, it's, it's like
where we came up short again.
We'll just have William
Shatner run a little longer.
Can TJ hooker like run half the length
of a football field before he catches up
to somebody a third of his fucking age?
I saw the one, uh, I got to
get this actress name. Um,
he was one of, he was one of my, uh,
one of my favorite actors when I
was growing up. He was in colors.
He was a Latino Dude.
He got hit by a drunk driver.
Unfortunately it was like 37
to 30, 38 years old. Hang on,
I've got to get this guy's
name. Uh, let's see. Colors.
I am D B. I didn't know Don
Cheadle was in that movie.
I got to watch that again.
That'd be one of his earliest ones.
I am on nightmare walking. Um,
it's something silver, I believe.
Trinidad Silva. So he was
in this episode of, um,
this episode of,
uh,
Tj hooker and it was fucking hilarious
because all of a sudden TJ hooker when
he's talking to would throw in some
fucking Latino words and it was only like
shit that like a white people
know like cake pastime,
fucking Agua. He said at one point, well
maybe if you stop back to like a polo,
like he threw in like chicken
and it's just like, yeah,
that's because the writing staff
ordered El Pollo Loco that day.
But Trinidad Silva, I believe
he was in the jerk. Um,
I think he was in the, well, you know
what, I want to look up his fucking,
this guy was amazing.
He was in Hill street blues.
He was in the jerk.
Yeah.
He actually died during the filming of
a underrated movie by Weird Al Yankovic
called UHF. I was in colors. Uh, yeah.
Hill street blues stir crazy.
He had such,
Amy died so young. Yeah, he was on Barney
Miller. I mean that this guy Lou grant,
the white shadow. The jerk.
Ms Guys. I am DB page Beretta.
Okay.
You know, granted, he played, played a
perp in all of those fucking things here.
He's probably fixing games in the white
shadow. That's the way it was back then.
And this guy somehow got through it and
opened the doors for a bunch of other
people. I hadn't seen him in a while.
It was great to see him. Trinidad,
silver look them up a 1915 and
1988. Unfortunately, he was, uh,
he was only 38 years old. Jesus
Christ, um, phenomenal actor them. Um,
all right, legal zoom. Last
one here. Legal Zoom. When
you run your own business,
when you know that time equals money,
it's not just an old saying, it's a fact.
So why Hawaii?
Her waste your valuable time dealing with
an issue that legal zoom can help you
with. I'm doing this because I'm going
to Mississippi and Alabama this weekend.
You may already know, put your hands in
the air and feel the spirit of Jesus.
They had over 2 million people have
used legal zoom to start their business.
But legal zoom services don't end there.
There's a kingdom waiting for you after
your kit. They're fucking website.
Running a business comes with
taxes, contracts, hiring employees,
and the devil basically a lot of fine
print and we all know that the devil's in
the details.
I'm sorry.
That's why legal zone built a network
of independent attorneys licensed in all
50 states, not in Puerto
Rico, not in our territories,
just the 50 states they can provide the
advice you need to get through the daily
grind of running your business. By
the way, everybody in Puerto Rico,
I hope you make it through this storm.
Good Lord.
Good Lord Man.
Okay.
Rogan scared the shit out of
me and I live in fucking la.
I can't imagine what this poor
people doing out there. Uh,
and you don't have to worry about billable
hours since legal zoom isn't a law
firm. Instead you can count on
upfront pricing and clarity.
Call to action and invest your time and
money and growing your business and let
legal zoom help you out with legal stuff.
For special savings,
be for special savings.
Be sure to enter Promo Code Bur bur
are and the referral box at checkout.
That's Promo Code [inaudible]
for special savings.
only@legalzoomdotcomhilegalzoom.com
all right,
I think that's the podcast for this week.
I'm going to go play some drums and he
barely relaxed. No, actually I'm not.
I gotta go write an episode.
Episode three
nine of a
season three of f is for
family were actually this week.
We're working on episode seven
so you not in the business.
The reason why it's called three
Oh nine three means season three.
I never knew what that meant. I finally
figured it out after three seasons.
I remember last year,
it's like we're working on two oh four
and I'd be sitting in the back of the
room like we're not on
the 200th fourth episode.
But I knew that sounded
stupid. So I finally just, I
finally just asked, you know,
then he felt it.
I felt all the writers looking at me like,
why is this hacky comedian in this
fucking room? You know? And it hurts.
Um, no kidding. My work with great
people in case any of them are listening.
And if you're the one person in
the writers from listening to your,
my favorite writer in the room.
Um,
so I'm writing the episode three Oh nine.
That's what I have to do today.
I just do like,
I do two scenes a day and
then I get through the script
and then I do like three
or four passes. I didn't do that last
year, but this year I'm going to do it.
And then,
uh,
I bring it in and then everybody just
guts the thing and maybe like three jokes
make it,
but you know,
it's all about making that template and
that's the game that everybody fucking
place. All right, so that's the podcast.
Let's go pats Dr fucking year off.
Right?
Who's going to step into Edelman shoes
before he comes back for the wonderful
playoff run? Okay. I hope it doesn't
come back too soon. You know?
Do you know why Edelman got hurt?
That was the curse of the
nude ESPN magazine issue.
You know what I mean?
I,
I can't remember the last time I laughed
harder than watching him jump through
the air, catch a ball and have it over
his junk. Is he through through the year?
That was one of the funniest
fucking things I've ever seen.
I just don't understand how a woman,
I dunno, maybe, I guess what else?
I just don't understand
how any level that is.
Anything other than fucking hilarious.
Naked men are just funny. I used to
do a bit, my accent, the naked man is,
is one or two things. It's either funny
or scary depending on what's happening.
Like if you're at a game and a naked guy
runs across the fucking field, I mean,
you're fucking on the ground laughing.
However,
if you're walking home late at night and
a naked guy jumps out of Bush, like, ah,
that's the scariest fucking
thing you'll ever see, right.
I'd rather see a fucking rattlesnake,
you know,
I would rather see that and I'm
terrified of fucking snakes. Okay.
Then to have some fucking naked
guy jump out of a fucking Bush. Um,
I probably should just given up that
information. All right. Anyways,
dude, let's troll them.
Um, anyways. All right.
That's the a the podcast for this
Thursday. Have a great weekend.
You can't enjoy the football game tonight
at the college football this weekend.
Maybe tune into Alabama,
Fresno state. I will be there.
I will be there and thank you to everybody
in shippy and a Alabama for a buying
the tickets. I'm going to come out
there with my Yankee Bullshit and uh,
telling you guys once again why
you lost that war. All right.
Enjoy the,
uh,
the music here and we're going to have
another half hour of stuff from a classic
podcast from a Thursday gone by in a
year that already happened or possibly
early this year. I don't
know what it is. All right.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and this is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 7th,
2009.
Happy Labor Day.
What are you guys doing today? Huh?
With your big bad days off? Uh,
what are you doing? You laying around you
becoming fat fucks. What are you doing?
You Barbecue when we're going over
to Carol's and we're going to have a
barbecue. You want to
come Steven? No, I don't.
I want to fucking drink and
forget that I married you Carol.
I'm sorry. I'm going to fuck, I'm
moving some shit around right now.
And this is the Monday
morning called podcast.
I'm going to hit cod past podcasts.
I'm actually gonna try to do some, uh,
something different this week because
it's such a special fucking holiday cause
it is Labor Day. Why do
they call Elumelu? Well, no,
I'm sorry. I always have to do a
tribute to fucking eighties comedy.
I'm actually watching a fucking, I watch
too much sports this weekend and I just,
uh,
watching the end of the Colorado Colorado
state football game and right after
it, um, I taped best
damn tough man. You know,
cause it game always goes longer than
it's a lotted so you have to take the next
show, listen to this fucking spazz.
He goes by the name of the coach.
This is the classic example of a scared
guy before a fight and he's trying to
turn that fear until like
some sort of fucking, uh,
courage. But it works. This guy goes
by the coach. This is hilarious.
They're actually showing them right now,
he's getting his gloves put on.
Listen to this maniac.
I Dunno,
you get to hear that.
But basically you standing there and he
just goes like at showtime and then he
just snaps. It's showtime. You
just, you got to, I'm sorry.
I don't even know if this
is even going to translate,
but I gotta I gotta get
the rest of this shit here.
I gotta get the other thing
that he fucking says here.
What the fuck is wrong with this stupid
piece of shit? Fucking God damn cable.
Anybody else have this fucking
problem with your cable?
All right.
Did I just delete it? Ah, you
fucking cunt. All right. Whatever.
God Damn it, that was going to be such as,
that was like my big fucking different,
uh, beginning that I was just going to
have there and I just ended up deleting it
because my fucking cable sucks. Yeah.
What are you going to do? It's a holiday,
right? I shouldn't even
be doing this. So anyway,
so the next time they come to him,
he's screaming some more.
So he goes out there and of course
he doesn't know how to fight.
He's flailing or flailing around with
this dude. And in the end, you know,
he gets knocked on his ass and he,
and he loses. So it's the, it's every,
basically, every time they show
the guy, he, he would say one,
the first little thing he would say
quietly and then he would just completely
flip out. I can't fucking believe I,
God, I deleted that. What an asshole.
So whatever. The guy ends up losing in the
end of the fight, he goes, uh, he goes,
I'm ready for some more. I ain't even
bleeding yet. And then he just snapped.
Ah, fuck. I don't know what Co,
what sport that guy, coaches.
But if I was playing on his team,
I would run through a fucking
wall for that guy. You know,
I don't know all the pens. Depends
on your personality, you know,
I like maniacs like that. God
dammit. I can't believe that. Fuck.
I knew that was going to happen. I
knew it was going to happen. You know,
it's the worst.
It was not on every bad enough.
If I had to try and rewind it and get
back to where the hell it was, but then,
then I, it comes up with the delete thing
and accidentally deleted it. I'm sorry.
Everybody. Ah, fuck. Where the hell do
you go from here? Um, it's Labor Day.
Well, what exactly are you
supposed to do on labor day?
Am I supposed to observe something
for all the people who died at work?
Do they have a little parade?
Do you guys like parades?
That was a little pathetic things with
the mediocrely talented people of your
town marched down your fucking street.
Isn't that the worst when you come from
a small town? It's just a numbers game.
I mean, how many truly fucking
talented people can there be?
But somehow they still have to
put together a band. You know,
some chick with braces playing a fucking
flute marching down the street and then
they always end it with
like a fire engine.
Just trying to drown out
your bad local band. My eight
or everybody's singing in monotone,
a bunch of dentists and accountants
sitting there with their fucking weird ass
looking kids.
God a buck a.
Do they do that today?
Is that what you're supposed to do?
Am I supposed to be dressed up
like it's the revolutionary war?
Reenacting something. I
gotta be honest with you. Uh,
Labor Day feels like every other fucking
day to me because I'm a comedian and
I'm always sitting in my underwear
at fucking 12 noon. All right?
That's why I do this. Do you think I
want to make you fucking people laugh?
I don't,
I don't.
I just remember when I was 14 sitting in
my underwear eating toast one day on a
Saturday morning and I was thinking,
would it be fucking great if I
could do this every day? You know,
wake up, watch cartoons,
wrestle with my fucking dog,
you know, and just have absolutely
no responsibility whatsoever.
And I got to tell you something.
I made that dream come true.
We get worried when you die. God's
just going to be looking at the video,
your life,
you know,
just looking at it then kind of
glancing over at you and just,
just shaking his head. Barely. You
get one shot at this and this was,
this is what you did.
Do you realize that you spend over 98,000
hours of your life in your underwear?
And I'm not even counting when you were
fucking sleeping. Oh, speaking of that,
the other day I met him still on,
I'm still sorry.
Nia just walked by laughing at
me like I'm an idiot. I, um,
I'm still on European time.
Um, today was the first day,
actually got up at nine o'clock.
I've basically,
I have been when I was over in Sweden.
How did you feel about that?
When I was over in Sweden,
uh, last week, um, Clia,
what are you doing?
You stop walking around like a creep.
My dog is like most big
dogs there. Uh, she's apt.
She doesn't realize how big
she is. And, uh, so she's,
but she's not afraid of a
lot of things. Uh, you know,
she's not afraid of other dogs, but
hardwood floors scare the shit out of her.
So she so worried that
she's going to be slipping.
She walks like really slowly in daintily
all around the apartment and it looks
like she's going to like sneak up on you
something that's right. Just laid out.
All right.
Ooh,
Ooh. I got to teach her how to howl. Oh,
you guys want to see something
fucking adorable. Do you want to see?
You want to see something that we'll,
we'll,
we'll make you actually believe again in
whatever the fuck you stopped believing
in. Go on Youtube and search a boxer, B o,
x,
e r and baby,
and there's a little baby playing with
a boxer and I'm telling you it's, it's,
it's one of the most adorable
things you'll ever see. You know,
there would be less violence in the
world if everybody watched this video.
Actually that's not true. Everyone would
watch the video and then the second,
somebody next to you in,
ah,
the rage would come back and you'd want
to just fucking blast him in the face.
But whatever, I digress. Let me get
back to what I was talking about. Um,
so anyways, so I have been when
I was over in speed and yeah,
I was up all night and uh,
and then I would sleep all day like
that awful heavy metal song by that band
slaughter and read that.
That's when you knew it was over.
Everybody said it was over when fucking
nirvana came out. No, it wasn't.
It was over when slaughter came out.
Slaughter,
slaughtered the rest of hair metal.
That awful guys voice
Zap.
No, it isn't right. It
isn't. It's fucking terrible.
Um, anyways, I'm plowing
head here. So, uh,
I finally got used to the time over in
Sweden and then I came back to the states
and now I'm on Sweden time.
So basically I have been up every fucking
night watching old football clips and
whatnot on, uh, on the Internet
and I call it all you guys all, uh,
sent me emails going, I swear to
God I don't work for the NFL man.
Just tell me where I can see them.
Where do you see all the videos?
Where is the main site where
everybody watches videos?
That's where the fuck they are.
Okay.
It rhymes with Mu Lube. Um, anyways,
so I,
that's what I've been doing late at night.
I've been watching these
fucking videos and uh,
what am I trying to say here? I
don't know what happened. So yeah.
So I fall asleep at la about six,
six 30 in the morning.
I sleep until one in the afternoon.
That's what has been happening to me.
I feel like a fucking drug addict.
Right. So evidently yesterday, um,
I was passed out and for some
reason I was in the nude.
All right, go ahead. Visualize that
one face down in the fucking nude.
And my girlfriend took a picture of me
because she thought it was funny and I
saw it and I,
I dunno,
I never really had a, Oh look, I never
thought it was a good looking guy,
but I thought it was all right.
I saw myself laying there butt
ass naked and I got to met. Dude,
I look like a fucking cadaver.
That was the worst part. It's not that I
looked at its shape. I'm in decent shape.
I just look like somebody just
had fished me out of a river.
That's the only way I could describe.
The only thing missing was bill
Curtis, his voice, just narrating.
I'm bill Curtis,
a pasty freckly man was fished out
of fuckhead river the other day.
This sleepy little town with their, with
the fuck. I was gonna say Memorial Day.
What the fuck is it? Labor
is Labor Day parade. Hey,
stupid can't with braces playing a flute.
It looks perfect and talks
looking at me right now going,
you do not sound like Bill
Curtis, whatever. I fucking
looked like it was dead,
so I deleted the picture and
then my girlfriend felt bad.
She goes, oh, I thought it was cute.
I didn't know how to make you
self conscious and it was cute.
It wasn't cute.
No one should see what they
look like face down naked.
Ah, I can't shake the image. I hope
you guys aren't having your fucking,
your traditional Labor Day breakfast
while not while you're, you're,
you're visualizing that Jesus Christ.
I look at that Rosetta stone.
Remember I was going to learn how to speak
Spanish. I just hate when you do that,
when you're like,
I'm gonna learn how to do this shit.
And you and you buy something and you
just stick it on your bookshelf and it's
just sitting there mocking your
laziness for the next nine months.
I got that for Christmas last year and I
cannot fucking say anything in Spanish.
You don't really get to do,
I'm just gonna go down to home depot and
I'm going to find one of those Mexican
dudes who are raw always asking me
if they can fucking rewire my entire
apartment for fucking three
because of the hardest,
hardest work in fucking
people on the planet. Um, and
I'm just, we had looked at,
why don't I just give you 20 bucks and
teach you and you just teach me how to
speak Spanish. Is that okay? And then
of course it'd be like, I nod. I Dunno.
I Dunno what I know I want,
I want you to teach me,
teach Amelia how to speak a I die.
I don't know.
Leave saying,
hey,
we just sit there for fucking an hour
and then after awhile my forehead,
would it be sunburned and I would
just give up. That's probably what,
what happened and who knows?
Maybe I would actually make a friend down
there and maybe he was really good at
an instrument and he
was slightly retarded.
And then I would draw that talent out.
And then some day a Freddie prince junior
would have a comeback plane. That dude,
and we can make a little Oscar winning
movie. Maybe that could happen.
All right, let's plow ahead.
Let's, let's, let's get, let's,
let's actually be smart this week.
And rather than waiting till 50
minutes into this podcast to hype,
what the fuck I have to hype.
Why don't I hype what I have to
hype right fucking now. Okay,
well I'm going to do that. Of
course. The second I say it,
my fucking computer shuts down. All
right, hang on a second. Um, all right.
This week I am going to be
in Philadelphia, Pennell,
Pennsylvania at the helium
comedy club. Um, September 10th,
11th and 12th. Um, for the love of
God, please come out to that show.
Please show up.
And a,
I got a brand new hour at least
since the last time I've been there,
cause I haven't been there
in like a year and a half.
And that's plenty of time for me to
come up with some new shit. So, uh,
please come down there. I'm actually
gonna try to go to a Phillies game,
check out that new stadium and uh,
what else am I going to do there?
I think that's it. I think
that's it. You know what,
somebody actually sent me an email,
you know,
cause last week I was telling
you guys about hiking,
watch those Superbowls clay out.
Would you just take a confidence
step in the apartment? Jesus Christ,
you would think there were
land mines under the floor.
The dog has never fallen down.
That's the funny thing.
I could see if she fell down the first
day she was here and then she'd have this
little, my God, Oh my God,
she's never fallen down
and I was just put that up to see a
scared pit bull, isn't it? Um, anyway,
so this guy actually told me about
a, uh, if you're into hockey,
hockey, I don't know, I just said
it that way if are into hockey. Um,
there's actually a fucking
website if I can find it. Uh,
where I was watching the
1974 Stanley Cup finals,
like game six. I had never seen it. Um,
and I was watching the Bruins verse the
flyers of course the flyers probably
when that fucking game, cause I know they
won the series and you have to go to,
uh, this is it right here. This
is for the sports fans out there.
It's h f boards,
B o a r d s.com/um,
actually,
you know what,
just go to that [inaudible] dot com and
just go to that and just start searching
for some games and they have all the
original games in their entirety.
And if you are a big sports fan,
like I,
it's great to watch those because you can
watch how the game has changed and all
that type of stuff.
I gotta be honest with me.
And I had like the greatest fucking
weekend ever where, um, you know,
just because college football started
and I don't really happen. Like two,
two years ago I became a college football
fucking maniac and I absolutely love
it. And um, I was actually
once again sleeping until noon,
which is fucking like three
o'clock east coast time.
So I missed like most of
the first games I think.
I think it was like missed like the
first three quarters of the first game.
So I wake up my girl, like she gives,
she would have made some breakfast.
She actually brings it into me.
I have breakfast in bed and I walked
into the living room after I eat it.
She just made me breakfast in bed people.
Okay.
And I fucking hinged and she goes in
to watch one of her reality shows and I
woke up and uh,
after I ate the breakfast,
I realized that I was missing
all these college games.
So I just stumbled in the living
room because when you're my age,
you stumble for the first hour when you
wake up because for some reason your
Achilles shrink up to your fucking the
bottom of your ass and your legs don't
work. Right. Right. So I
stumbled in here and uh,
I just took the remote from
our, usually I say, honey, you,
would you mind if I just Kinda,
I didn't,
I just fucking walked in and
I put on the USC game and uh,
she rightfully just looked down
at the floor. Like, really?
I just made you fucking steak and eggs
and you fucking just come wandering in
here. And then she just sort of walked
out and then I had to do that pathetic.
You know when you want to apologize
for something you just did,
but you want to continue
doing the thing that you're,
that you're apologizing for.
So rather than hitting pause,
I kept watching the game,
like yelling out the side of my
mouth as she was walking away.
Sorry honey. I do. And
I just continued to watch the game and
she gave me the silent treatment for the
next four hours,
which actually worked out good.
I think I watched like 12
football games this weekend.
I don't know why anybody gets to
fucking NFL package. You don't need it.
You can get all the, all the college
games you want for free and a,
and the kids are young. They haven't
blown out there needs to fucking maniacs.
Nobody's holding out. I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck of saying.
You know,
it's getting hot in here cause I have
to close my God damn windows because I
curse too much when I do this.
You know what? I actually,
I have some more audio here.
Let me take a actually a sip of water.
Like I'm Frank Sinatra in
between fucking songs here
then ain't water. All right. Um,
you ever hear him say that he makes a
joke back then when it was funny that you
were drinking booze on stage?
Um,
I actually found another record.
If you guys are actually
big fans of my podcast,
you know what sucks about this shit as
I have to literally move my mixer and
everything else, listen to it, hit
the floor so you didn't hear that.
And then we'd go, God damn
these fucking wires. Um,
I've been slowly but surely.
And that's how you, he never say it had
been slowly. You always have to say,
but surely he always said that they
think they go together. You know,
sick and tired.
Slowly but surely suck my dick.
Look my balls. You know, it all goes
together. All right, here we go.
I've been basically buying my dad's
record collection one album at a time.
And this is one of the weirdest
fucking albums my dad had as a kid,
but because I was a kid and I
didn't know any better, I loved it.
Listen to this shit. This is
basically the original, like,
you know when you watch Austin Powers
and they're kind of mocking the weird
music of the 60s.
This is basically why this is a
called persuasive percussion 1966.
And in defense of the orchestra, I think
that they were trying to demonstrate, um,
as many instruments as
they possibly could,
isolated how good they sound and
the new found high fi stereo.
So here we go,
listen to this shit.
Okay,
any day now.
How's that?
The Shit of what?
Okay.
Uh, you know, a lot of
people, if they saved,
they'd go back in a time machine that they
would go back and try and stop Hitler.
I wouldn't,
I go back to this fucking
recording session because I
just want to see the looks
on people's faces when they
played their kind of music.
I always picture Barney Rubble's face,
you know,
when he was playing the drums in
that one Fred Flintstone episode,
we got Barney rubble Logan for travel.
And he had like,
his eyes were all squinted.
Like that's,
I just picture all these guys and like
fucking those turtle necks with, with the,
uh, the peace sign. Remember how buddy
rich was, was dressing and like the, uh,
the early seventies when he was trying
to act like he was still going to stay
relevant with these new hip Kooky kids,
but he was still playing big band music
and he would come out with like these
plaid Johnny Carson fucking Hagar slacks,
a knitted turtleneck, and then on
the outside of the turtle neck, um,
a little precursor to Eddie Murphy's,
a pinky ring on the outside of his glove.
He would have his, he'd have his
necklace outside the turtleneck with a,
with a peace sign and it was
all in like silver, I dunno.
And he let his hair grow a little long
and he had that awful fucking to pay,
but he still was fucking fantastic.
All right.
Was that worth the trip all the
way over to my high Pfiesteria.
Do you guys have a hi Fi? Huh?
All right. Sorry about that.
I'm a fucking nerd. So that's basically
what I did all this weekend. I, uh,
listened to bad records and I,
I was listening to and watching all
these football games and I got to admit,
you got to watch his old football games
because it is such bullshit nowadays the
way they, they don't let these
fucking wide receivers can,
they can do whatever they want. You can't
even cover the fucking receivers. Huh?
Any Georgia bulldog fans out there. How
bad did you guys get fucked on that call?
I'm not saying that you
would have won the game,
but that was definitely
a pivotal fucking moment.
This guy is going over the middle, the
ball, his throne high and the defense,
the defensive back lays them out. That's
football and then like, and Yancy,
stammering,
Yay and nay hearing that
roughness was unnecessary.
Who's fucking pathetic?
I mean, unnecessary.
I'm doing my fucking job.
If you want to see how far football is
changed, a fuck it. Who gives a shit?
Go on to youtube and just fucking search.
Um,
search 1978 AFC championship game,
uh,
Steelers versus the Houston Oilers and
watch part for go all the way to the end.
You're going to see Mike Barbara goes
over the middle. Dan Pastor Rini,
the fucking douchebag throws it like
nine feet over his head. But my Mike,
Barbara's a Gamer, right? So he goes
up for the thing. Mike Wagner comes in,
doesn't even look at the ball and just
fucking goes as low as he possibly can.
Hits Mike Barber right on his, God Damn
Nice. You ever see a guy on youtube?
You ever watch a guy like
slam into offense doing 80
miles an hour on a fucking
motorcycle. And that way,
you know, you just launch,
it's like you're standing up in the air,
but you're doing flips, head over heels.
That's what he did. He flipped
it, flipped around like twice,
landed on this astro turf and he's holding
his fucking knee and flipping out and
he, you know, he's on the ground for
like five minutes. When he gets up,
he's pointing at Mike, Mike
Wagner, you mother Fucker,
you cheat motherfuckers screaming all
this stuff and the announcers in the booth
and just sitting there going like, well,
you know, Mike wasn't looking at the ball.
So, uh, I mean, I dunno, I'm Mr Barbara is
really, he's really annoyed. But I mean,
he was just doing his job. He's
just doing his job. You know,
there was no unnecessary roughness.
Actually, there was back then,
but you actually had to do
something that was unnecessary.
Now you're doing the necessary shit.
It is to cover a fucking receiver
and they go, it's unnecessary.
That's why one of the biggest bullshit
records ever broken was Dan Marino's
touchdown record by Peyton manning.
Remember that year when he cried because
the fucking patriots diff diff players
actually covered his fucking receivers.
You Ne we're trying too hard.
And the next thing you know,
you can't even touch these fucking guys.
And he breaks Dan Marino's record Dan
Marino where to thrown 90 touchdowns if
you couldn't touch Clayton and duper.
All right, that's it. I'm done.
I'm done with this sports this week cause
I know people like I know at one point
and he went once and then when you take
him on boards, they get bored. Well,
you know something. Listen to
another fucking podcast. All right,
you're whiny cunt.
Go enjoy your fucking Labor Day
on somebody else's podcast. Ah,
how do you like that? Look at me getting
all tough. All right, you're gonna.
You guys want to,
um oh wait real quick.
Um, my team is a Lsu. I think
I'm gonna go with Lsu this year.
There's some bought that les miles.
I just liked the Guy Fourth and 12,
two minutes into the game
and he fucking goes forward.
This is like a direct quote for him.
They go less.
Why do you always go for it on fourth
down? And he says, well, you know what,
when you have play makers on your team,
you have an obligation to turn them loose.
That might be one of the
greatest quotes ever.
I love the southern
fucking turn them loose.
You got play makers on your
team buddy. Okay, you follow me?
You have an obligation. Turn them
loose. Just turn them dogs loose.
Just see what to come up with. Go out
there and dig up fucking first down.
Greatest fucking fake field goal
of all time. Lsu. Look that up.
Lsu fake field goal. It's the smoothest
shit you're ever going to see.
Just flips it right over
his God damn shoulder.
I was fucking them as a thing of beauty.
All right,
here's some youtube videos for you guys.
If you're new to my podcast,
this is what I do every week. I act like
a fucking moron in my apartment and um,
people send me in these youtube videos. I
already gave you the boxer baby one. Um,
and the Lsu fake field goal. And
uh, this is just a creepy one.
It's really quick, but it's
really creepy. Look up, um,
animal recording fail,
animal recording fail.
It's somebody's filming an Anaconda or
some big ass fucking snake and evidently
the snake was not ready
for, it's a closeup. Okay,
we'll just leave it at that and a,
and I'll make it jump.
It'll fucking Mickey jump. All right,
this is going to be a quick podcast.
I'm already to the questions
and I'm only 24 minutes.
And you know what this feels like.
This feels like when I'm fucking
bombing on stage and I'm,
I know a lot of you guys out there and
not comedians. Sure. We all aren't.
And uh, basically what happens is
when you're having a great set,
all right, say you're slated
to do 50 minutes, okay?
Somebody comes back and they say,
Hey kid, can you give me 50 minutes?
Can you go out there and give
it the college track? Right?
And you fucking go out there and you
start killing. And if you're killing,
and if you're totally on,
what ends up happening is
you do 50 minutes and you
feel like you only did half
your act, you know, but on
nights when you're bombing,
you're about to jokes away
from your closing bit,
and you look down at your watch and
you're about 12 minutes into your set.
And that's when the dry mouth
sets in and you're like, okay.
Uh, so, uh, what do you
do for a living? Oh yeah,
here's my cute little jokes about
fucking plumbers, you know? Oh,
that's the worst I ever tell you about
to send my first headlining gigs.
This is basically how I became a headliner
was a first year I had to write the
material. All right? And
I had gotten up to a,
I knew I had 45 minutes,
but I had never done 45 minutes.
And when you headline or go on last or
whatever the fuck you want to call it, um,
on a real show as a headliner,
you have to do at least 45 minutes.
That's how it works.
Okay.
I don't know where the fuck you
guys are from where I'm from.
That's how it fucking works.
You've got to do 45 minutes.
So I had been doing standup for
about three and a half, four years.
So I had written 45 minutes of material,
but I had never done 45 minutes.
You know what I mean?
I was basically, at that point, I was a,
I was the feature act or the second guy.
So I was doing like anywhere from 20
minutes to 30 minutes at the most.
Usually Feature Act does 20 to 25 30
if you work at working with like an old
bitter headliner who's given into the
fact that he's not gonna make it or maybe
he just doesn't feel like
doing it. Um, you know,
that's when you work with those guys.
And she said, they just come up to you.
And then I worked with this guy one
time when he looks at me and he goes,
he goes, hey, kid, kid. Uh, he goes, Huh,
how much time do you get? Um, I dunno, uh,
30, 35. And he just goes do all of it.
He's just like, dude, your whole
fucking act, play with the crowd.
I don't give a shit. I'll fucking do 11
minutes and close the show. I've had it.
Right. So, um, anyways, yeah.
So I'd written 45 minutes
of material and I uh,
but I'd never done it all in a row,
so I didn't know how to put it together.
So when I moved down in New York,
you know,
the only way to start headlining is at
some point you got to bite the bullet and
just tell somebody that you're a
headliner. You don't tell that to a,
to a good room. You tell it to like, you
know, you have a rooms, you have be rooms,
you got C and d rooms, so like to c and d
rooms. I was like, I just told the guys,
yeah, I'm a headliner. And
I looking at me, you know, I
was just a kid. They're like,
you're a headliner. And I'm like,
yeah, yeah, I'm a headliner. You know,
it's like when we try and get served,
when you're under age,
you just try to have that look
of confidence. Don't flinch.
Just give him the money. I would
like a vodka. Collins. Yes, I would.
Me and my one whisker on my chin
would like to have some alcohol.
Thank you very much. And um,
the first time I headlined,
I remember I went on after this,
this uh,
this black dude was on in front of me
and he was totally like high energy to
begin with.
And that's one of the first things you
learn how to do as a headline is how to
follow somebody if they have
high fucking energy. Right?
So this guy is doing his act and you know
it like it is, you know, he's
been doing it for a long time.
So he just keeps building with the energy
building and building and building.
And he ended his act doing some jokes
about like a prostate exam and by the end
he's just screaming
and he's got his fucking,
thank God my mother Fucker
is screaming into this,
my killing in this restaurant
and I'm sitting there,
I'm already sweating trying to think how
the fuck am I going to follow that guy.
And I made the biggest fucking mistake
you can ever do is when somebody ends and
they're on 11 with the energy,
the worst fucking thing that you can do
is to go on stage and start your act at
the same energy that that, that
that guy left off. First of all,
you're not going to have enough
energy. There's no way. You can't
be on 10 for 45 fucking minutes.
You're going to pass out.
Okay. And not only that, it's bizarre
to have someone just come out on stage,
you know, please welcome
bill burr screaming.
I said, I like that guy in the tough man
thing, you know, you got to get psyched,
you got to get pumped. I was coming
out with like that kind of energy.
So I went up there and eight
minutes in screaming my act,
I am pouring sweat and I remember looking
down at my watch feeling like I had
done at least 25 minutes and I had
only done like 11 minutes and I,
I was out of breath out of breath
from telling fucking jokes.
And I had no,
I just remember there was a,
for some reason there was a big fish tank
in this place and I was trying to riff
about the fish tank and it was a
restaurant and like a, anybody oded,
the filet of fish goes, I think I know
where they got it. It was, it was awful.
Oh, just fucking, Oh I, you know
what actually got a bad feeling.
Just even thinking about that fucking set.
So if you are a comedian and you're
listening to this and you're just starting
to headline,
if you follow somebody with energy,
what you actually want to do is
go in the opposite direction.
That's what I learned as you go up there
and you just start really fucking slow
and actually kind of eat your balls for,
you know,
just let everybody just bring it down.
Everybody fucking relax.
And then when she get him relaxed,
then you start to build them up again.
You know what I mean? It's just like
doing drugs. You start coming down,
but you know, once you go through the
floor and you start filling depression,
you take another drug and you
start coming back up again. That's,
that's where right there,
right as you go below the floor boards,
that's when I grabbed you by the back of
your fucking God damn shirt and I pull
you back up again, comedically. And
then we, then we go back up again.
But this is what,
what ended up happening was I would do
my jokes and I could kill for 37 minutes.
And for some reason
when I said 37 minutes,
I just wrote it on my Ottoman
with my finger. I wrote 37,
like the fucking rain man,
fucking Weirdo.
I really have a lot of rain man qualities.
I don't know if you've noticed that,
but uh,
like
I can actually name all
everybody who's won the Superbowl
the last 43 years and now I don't have
it in front of me, but I can do it.
So if you ever see me, I'll fucking
rattled them off, rattle them off.
I had my head to the side just
like the fucking rain man.
And they just want me to go back and name
all the losers. I can fucking do that.
And uh,
I was actually at 1.1 to,
to memorize where all the Superbowls
took place and that's when, uh,
right after I had that thought,
I kind of caught myself in a mirror
and I was just like, what are you doing
bill? What, what, what do you,
what do you run it from? You know,
because I'm just sitting there in the
mirror going green bay, Green Bay jets,
chiefs, colts, cowboys, dolphins,
dolphins, Steelers, Steelers. Yeah,
Raiders, cowboys. See, can
I still do it? Steelers,
Steelers and then Jim Plunkett
with the fucking Raiders.
Jill Montana. That was
in Pontiac, Michigan.
They beat the Bengals and they stopped
Pete Johnson right down the goal line and
then the fucking Redskins who I hated
because I was a huge cowboy fan.
They'd beat the dolphins that Fulton
Walker and took the kickoff back.
See,
I remember all this shit
and the rate has kicked the shit out of
the Redskins and next year and then a
fucking 40 niners beat the dolphins.
Remember that sports illustrated with
Dan Marino was on the cover and he was
pointing at him like, yeah, this is
going to be the first one, right.
With Joe Montana. Next year was
the bears, which could have,
should have been the greatest
fucking Superbowl ever. You know,
I'm just going all sports this week.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm just going to give you guys
a heads up. Do you remember that?
The bears went 15 and one
in the regular season.
Okay. And the only team they lost to
was the dolphins on a Monday night.
It was fucking awesome cause the dolphins
basically defended the 72 dolphins,
you know, undefeated record
by beating the fucking bears.
So in the AFC championship game that year,
it was the dolphins first,
the Patriots, and we were
playing them in the orange bowl.
And we had this curse we had,
we had never won in the
orange bowl for like fucking,
I don't like 20 goddamn years.
Okay.
Since like Lyndon Johnson was an office
and the San Diego chargers played in Los
Angeles. Okay. And, and um,
the fucking dolphin should have beat
us and then they should've gone to the
Superbowl and then the bears should have
been set up to fucking avenge their one
loss of the year.
And then the dolphins with Dan Marino.
And that unbelievable fucking offense
was the only ones that was able to beat
the 46 defense.
And what fucking happens.
Stupid ass patriots. We come in
there and we beat them. Right.
And then, you know, let's
squish the fish. Remember that,
squish the fish and everybody.
Miami was just so like, Ooh,
Dolphin join of foods.
There are minimal. Hello
was some of the gay as shit
talking ever during that time.
And somebody who made a song in Boston,
remember that song by Pete Townsend, uh,
face to face that face to face, gat
to face to face, something like that.
Somebody wrote us a squished the
fish to that song, squish the fish,
get to squish the,
if it was fucking horrific,
but somehow I still actually watch
the game. And then the Patriots got a,
they got raped, I believe is the best
way to describe it, um, by the bears.
46 to 10.
Then the next year was the giants.
Then the red skins than
40 niners 40 niners.
And then was the bill's error where they
lost to the giants, Redskins, cowboys,
cowboys. Then the 40 niners,
then the cowboys and the
packers. And then the pack.
Uh, you had a packers
beat the fucking patriots.
I went to that game than the Broncos
won the next two. Then the rams,
then the ravens. Stupid. Ah,
that coach there and they have no
idea how fast we shut up the clown.
They beat the giants then patriots,
then Tampa, patriots, patriots,
Holts stealers. Giants stealers.
Huh? You like that Shit
fucking rain man. What do you want to
go another sport? Name another sport.
I'll fucking do it. I can go all the
way back to like the early seventies.
That's what I,
I actually fucking sit there and
I write that down on like Napkins,
cocktail napkins. When I'm on planes.
Like that's how I make plane rides go by.
Like right now, maybe you're on
a plane listening to this shit.
I actually sit there.
Green Bay, Green Bay jets.
Yeah, definitely the chiefs
and I'm a fucking loser.
All right,
let's get to some of the questions
here for the week. Jesus Christ. Nia.
Okay.
This is what happens when
I'm doing my fucking podcast.
Nia is always getting ready
to go somewhere and she
comes out in all sorts of
fucking different dress.
Okay.
And I'm not ready for it.
Um,
you just tell her you were going to go do
one of those sports illustrated covers.
Some of those ones where they were the
mesh, this bathing suit. Yeah, exactly.
All right. Let's plow ahead here.
Um, questions of the week. All right.
Question number one. Hey Bill, I'm sure
you've by now you've seen the punch.
Just wondering what your
opinion was on it. Personally,
I thought the Boise state player deserved
it and the expression on his face was
priceless. Go blue. All right.
There's a Michigan Fan are,
unless you're saying go blue
because of the fucking turf. Um,
um, okay. How do I explain this shit?
This is basically what happened.
Boise state played a, played Oregon
and I guess last year, Boise State,
I'm injured
the quarterback on a fucking,
I was just picturing that dude
from England getting all pissed.
Well, it's none of this shit because I
know he doesn't give a fuck about all this
stuff, but I don't give a fuck.
You don't watch this stuff.
I'll talk about the premier
league next week. So anyways,
somebody in Boise state injured
the quarterback on Oregon.
So the running back on Oregon.
Okay.
Since we, we owe Boise
state, uh, and ass weapon.
So we use basically talking shit.
So they play the game and they held that
guy who talks shit to minus five yards.
So at the end of the game that came up
and they talked a little bit of Shit.
The guy gets in his face as Fabi like,
ah, where are you going to say now man,
what are you guys?
And then the dude looks away and the
dude who was getting yelled at just wound
up and he fucking dropped
the guy and then it,
then it just got ugly and ugly and
ugly. What do I think about that? Um,
it was definitely funny.
There's definitely funny to see it when
you see a guy getting somebodies face
talking a bunch of shit and then
the other guy just, you know,
just fucking winds up and drops him.
It was definitely funny, but uh,
I thought that dude had it coming. You
know, if you're going to say, you know,
you got an ass whooping common.
If you're going to talk shit and
then only get minus five yards,
you got understand that people are
going to give you some shit back. And a,
I gotta be honest, man, I feel really
bad for that guy because uh,
you know,
he could've got drafted and
now he got suspended and um,
and just one of those heat of the moment
things were, I don't know, at some point,
you know, I mean he might've
just fucked his whole life up.
Yeah.
Like now, now he won't get
drafted and then what do you do?
Yeah,
you work at best buy, you could have,
you know, you could have gotten at least,
you know,
even if you suck,
you're going to get like six figure
contract maybe for a couple of years.
You run around and play for the
fucking chiefs or some shit like that.
I don't know. It was just really
bad. It was fucking ugly and a,
and then the fact that it was a black
dude and he punches a white dude.
Then you go on the internet and
everybody has to write some racist shit,
which is one of the things I really
can't stand about. Youtube is all the,
all the, uh, all the racist on there.
I really can't fucking stand that.
I don't mind when someone writes some
shit just to be a dick to annoy somebody,
but like a,
yeah,
yeah.
The n word is used pretty liberally on
youtube and that's the one fucking thing,
you know, somebody asked me that actually
about my website was saying like,
you know, why don't you have a
page where people can, you know,
leave comments and stuff like that.
And that's why I don't,
because people ended up arguing and then
invariably somebody writes something
racist or something just really horrific,
uh,
some about Jews or something.
And then it's on my website.
It's just, I, you know,
I don't condone that shit and I just,
you know, I don't give a fuck what I do.
The podcast.
Do you want to,
you want to write something or send it
to me and I'll fucking read it on this?
Um, I dunno that I explained
that I, I feel bad for that guy.
I feel bad for that dude because
he just fucked his life up.
And one moment by punching the guy
in the face, but you don't see them.
I don't like,
I don't like when people sucker punch
somebody and then they have like that.
Yeah. What, what fucking vibe?
What do you mean what? Uh,
I wasn't looking at you when you punch me
in the face. Yeah, I'm going to go down.
That's really, it's really no skill
level there, but in defense of that guy,
if you do get in somebody's
face and talk shit, yeah, you,
what you do is that you do that little,
you know that little gay backwards
skip that fucking football players do.
That's what you do while you look
at the person. You don't say a,
you don't talk shit and then just fucking
turn the other cheek like you're Jesus.
You know? Do you think Jesus ever
got dropped with that whole fucking a
wait, did he, did Jesus say that? Talk
Shit and then turn the other cheek?
He didn't say that.
He said if somebody slaps you,
turn the other cheek so they can slap
that side. What kind of a fucking,
you know, woe is me. That's
how I am not religious.
I can't get behind that son of God, not
son of God. Profit or whatever that is.
Just,
just some dumb shit,
son. If somebody kicks you
in the left ball when you,
I stopped watering and you can
actually see your right ball.
Hold it out for him so he can kick
with that one. Yeah, go fuck yourself.
You fucking
Hippie your stupid ass sandals.
He really was the original fucking dirty
ass hippie wasn't he wasn't Jesus that
all right. That should get some people
sending me some emails. God help me.
If I ever get fucking famous and they
start cutting up some of the Goddamn shit
on this podcast, I'm really going to be
in trouble. Um, all right, next question.
Bill, did you ever, uh, at some
point in your early career,
think about performing on a cruise ship?
This guy has no idea how
funny this question is. Uh,
I'm not sure if you've ever taken a
cruise before, but let me tell you,
it's pretty fucking sweet.
Okay. He says, uh,
it seems like you literally a would
be getting paid to go on vacation,
get shit faced daily and flirt with
some finance trim in between all that.
If you could find the time on Tuesday
and Thursday night to do your act for an
hour in the main show room.
Um,
not to mention you're waking up in some
of the sickest places in the Caribbean
every other day.
Let me know what you think.
All right? Um, okay. Amongst comedians,
you are never further out of
show business then when you do,
when you do stand up on a cruise ship,
um,
people who do stand up on cruise
ships, it's basically, uh,
I dunno,
it's,
it's like there's two places where
you go out to pasture as a performer.
Um,
Vegas and cruise ships.
Vegas isn't bad because you'll get like
$1 million fucking like that. Danny Gans.
Dot. Guy Just fucking passed away. Like
that guy was making millions. He had like,
he was making like five, 6 million a
year. He doesn't have to be on the road.
You let the crowd come to you. There's
a lot to say about that shit. But, uh,
when you're out on a cruise
ship, I mean, first of all,
let's just break this
whole fucking thing down.
It seems like you'd literally be
getting paid to go on a vacation. Yeah.
Except you have to work.
That's actually one of the classic things
that club owners used to do when I was
starting out to try and fuck you over.
When they would try to book you down in
Florida in the wintertime and they'd off,
you're like 80 bucks for the week or some
awful shit. And they'd be like, yeah,
but you know,
it's kind of like you're on vacation.
It's kind of like a paid vacation.
Yeah.
Except I have to work except for that
working part. You fucking assholes.
Um, now, uh, a cruise ship is an absolute
fucking nightmare, believe it or not.
One of the first things you
want to do as a performer,
the second the show is over, is you want
to get the fuck away from the crowd.
You want to get away from
the crowd because the only
way to describe it is you,
you ever get stuck in an elevator with
some douche bag and you have to make this
small talk conversation
that you don't want to have.
Imagine being stuck on a boat with a
fucking a thousand of those people.
Cause that's basically what it is.
Now.
I'm not trying to be unappreciative of
people will come out to see the fucking
show, but you know, I dunno.
What do you do for a living?
Okay, let's use the plumber
analogy. Does that guy,
I want to talk fixing fucking toilets.
How did you get into fixing toilet?
Do you get nervous right before
you have to fix a toilet?
You know, it's awful.
I did one cruise ship
and I actually, uh, I got, I
didn't, I need to get fired,
but I was definitely not asked back.
And uh, the whole thing was a lie.
They told me, I told him, first of all,
I said that my act is not
conducive to a cruise ship.
I just don't see myself doing well on a
cruise ship. And uh, they were like, no,
you know, cause people are old on
cruise ships and they're like, Nah,
this is a young hip cruise ship.
I already told this fucking story.
And I got on there,
there was that old
Vietnamese woman passed out,
missing all their fucking teeth upfront
and I ate my balls the entire week.
And the only people I made
laugh was the band. You know,
the captain wrote a letter saying,
how is offensive to all fucking people?
And cruise ships are a nightmare,
sir. They're a fucking nightmare.
And I don't know what cruise
ship that you're taking, but um,
all I know is that when
I took a cruise ship,
they would stop and you had basically
four hours to see whatever the fuck you
could see before you had to run back to
the ship or they would leave without you.
So it was a very stressful situation.
And then other than that,
you were just out on the water and
it all looked the fucking same to me.
Okay.
Maybe I didn't take a good one.
I mean,
if I went to the Mediterranean
and did a European cruise,
imagine that would be
cool. But, uh, you know,
I don't want to go to Athens
for fucking three hours,
you know,
and fucking sitting there running around
trying to see all this shit, you know,
in flip flops and a fucking Hawaiian
shirt, you know, dressed like
Robin Williams before he does God damn
special. Um, it's, it's a nightmare Gig,
sir. They definitely pay
well, but it is, it's,
it's a fucking nightmare
and you're out to sea.
And I don't know when I did them,
they didn't even have Internet access.
So there was no way for your fucking
agent to even get in contact with you if
you did have a big audition.
But even if he did have a big auditions,
now you can fucking get off the boat.
Okay.
You know, call a fucking helicopter
helicopter, you know, it's, it's horrific.
Anyways, let's plow ahead here. Um,
it's getting hot as fuck
here in my apartment because
I had to close the windows
because I curse. Um, what
is this section here?
Something I wasn't aware of. I don't even
know what this is. Let me read this. Um,
the reason I'm writing you is
I'm a huge college football fan,
but I have to say that there is one trend
that has emerged over the past decade
that really bugs the shit out of me.
Oh, this guy doesn't like the promos.
I haven't, has anybody got any other
football fans? No to this. He said,
why is it that every major
football telecast kicks off
with some redneck singing?
A theme song?
I guess it started with Hank Williams
jr now that's the only one I know that I
ever read. It wasn't
football. Shamona not part.
I fucking hate that. I don't like
that one either. But I wasn't aware.
He's saying they're doing it everywhere.
He said it's gotten way out of hand.
A few years ago, college game
day employed it's own country,
mute music band to sing the show's theme.
It's like the guy with the fiddle.
Um,
and the guy wearing the big
top hat are supposed to be a little less
white trash because they're joined by a
black guy shouting out football
audibles in the middle of the song.
Wow. Dude, that sounds
fucking horrific. Um,
this year to top it all off,
all the day apparently isn't complete
unless some other Appalachian with a 10
gallon hat sings the scene theme song
for ABC's game of the week on Saturday
night.
Not to mention that during the actual
game the ACC has its own commercial with
some other hicks singing a theme song at
least that is somewhat understandable.
The AACC is predominantly
um, uh, southern conference
coffee conference.
Such a moron.
All right, look, I get it.
College football has a lot of fans
in the southeast part of the country.
Football in general attracts
a large audience of white
males between the ages of
25 to 40. I am one of those
white males. And frankly,
I'm a little tired of my football viewing
experience becoming intruded on by an
assorted cast of characters from
Hazard County. Sorry for the rant,
but I had to get that off my chest and
frankly my wife couldn't care less.
Okay. Oh Dude, I'm in that boat.
I know that you start rant to your
girlfriend about some shit and they just
start glazing over. Like, yeah,
I really don't care about sports.
So at any point,
if you want to stop yelling at me,
you're spending on the side of my
face, by the way. Um, yeah dude,
I gotta admit I haven't noticed that shit.
But I'll tell you why.
Cause I don't watch pregame post game.
I don't, I just watched the games.
I don't want to watch that part where
people like, you know, I'll tell you,
you know, if I'm Terry Bradshaw,
I got gotta be taken a,
what's John Stallworth doing?
Fuck. Give a shit. You know,
and I don't listen to sports talk radio.
All those people fucking freaking out
losing their minds here in Oklahoma.
He wants your starting quarterback
put the second stringer in. Relax.
That's why they have coaches. You
don't have to worry about it, sir.
The decisions will be made.
Um, alright. Underrated. Overrated
for the week. Uh, underrated.
The television series,
brotherhood. Um, dude,
the Brotherhood was my show and
they actually canceled it. Um,
this is what this guy has to say about,
he says a crime show on
showtime was recently canceled,
was much better than the similar,
the soprano's.
It had superior writing and acting.
It also had a better place and his
characters were much more interesting. Um,
it could be just be that the whole
Italian mafia thing is getting tired,
John Hra, but, um,
but I got to go with Brotherhood
as overall being a better show,
although they were both good.
Uh, yeah, the Brotherhood is
awesome, man. If you guys,
uh, have a DVD store
around you, what sucks is,
is this too awesome seasons
and they're really the,
the cliffhanger that they left you with.
It's basically based on that.
I think the Billy and Whitey Bolger thing,
we're back in Massachusetts,
they had a really high ranking politician
whose brother was a really high ranking
gangster.
Yeah.
And uh, this is something else I think
I already talked about on the podcast.
Yeah. That was like the dynamic and
everyone would always be asking the, uh,
was I think it was,
it was Billy Billy Ball jar,
I think was the politician
and Whitey was the gangster.
And they would always ask Billy be
like, what is your affiliation? I, dude,
I don't have any affiliation
with my brother, you know,
Massachusetts, my brother.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm just trying to do the best job I can
do to the tax payers of Massachusetts,
you know,
and the last thing I remembered happening
was the gangster actually won the
state lottery.
How fucking hilarious is that?
So this basically the show was based
on that took place in Providence,
Rhode Island. I highly, highly
fucking recommend that you watch it.
It sucks that there's only two seasons,
but um, starts off a little slow.
There's a lot of fucking,
uh,
yeah,
there's a lot of characters,
but um,
okay.
Actually at one point I'm actually
going to give away something.
This is just sort of a little vignette
that they had on the show is a Yankee fan
comes into one of the provenance bars
and starts talking shit to one of the
hothead gangsters and who's a red sox fan.
And um,
he fucking blows his brains out.
Okay.
And it,
it was really, it was disturbing.
It was disturbing. Um,
so definitely checked out and that
fucking guy was a great actor.
And not to mention that I'm
the guy who plays Freddy Cork,
um,
is actually,
believe it or not because he's such a
great fucking actor is Kevin Chapman who
was a comedian that I started out with
and he was one of my feet that was one of
my favorite characters on
TV and Tony Vee was in it,
another great comedian from Boston.
I'm so fucking pissed that they
canceled that show cause uh,
that was my show man. I love that
show. So I got to go with you. Yeah,
a brotherhood. Definitely
underrated. Alright. Overrated. Uh,
this dude says the black eyed peas,
the sheer amount of times I've heard the
new album against my will is staggering.
The only people you'll catch
listening to them are the lame ass.
Want to be cool white people who have
never heard of anything unless it was on
the radio. Yeah, I know. They
definitely play them in elevators.
And if you go to staples,
um,
I can't even think of their fucking
music, but I can't stand. Ah,
did they do London Bridge always that,
that check when she went solo.
Oh, that was Fergie by herself.
Oh, that's right. I'm sorry. Yeah.
You know what I actually
discovered the other day,
I have a lot of shit in my iPod that
my girlfriend downloaded on her fucking
computer was on the blink. And
uh, did I say on the blink?
I don't know what the fuck that means
when it was on the Fritz. He, uh,
so she downloaded all this shit
that I never would have listened to.
So the other day, what was that
song? I crazy. Who sings that song?
Yeah.
GNARLS Barkley. I never,
she used to listen to that
song and I fucking hated it.
Um, with that dude singing in
that falsetto, you know. Uh,
but I actually listen to the lyrics.
It's, I actually like the song now.
I was at the gym lifting weights,
listening to that song and I've
never felt gay or in my life. Uh,
I gotta wrap this up cause that was
embarrassing to even admit that. Um,
all right, I'm 53 minutes then. That's
going to be the podcast this week.
I know it's a little fucking, it was
little off this week I think, but um,
I'm coming down off a Tylenol pm.
I had to do it to,
I had to drag myself up like fucking
Michael Jackson so I could actually fall
asleep by two at night so I could wake
up and actually try and do this thing at
some point remotely near Monday morning.
I hope you enjoyed this podcast this week.
I hope you guys had a great
Labor Day weekend. I apologize.
I can't believe I deleted that,
that rant at debt boxer was doing.
It was fucking great.
The coach look out for him.
He's a tough man and evidently he's
ready for more cause he only started
bleeding. He always started
bleeding. All right, that's it.
Please continue to listen to the
podcast. I'm going to be at the, um,
helium comedy club this weekend
in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
Please come down to the show and
also, uh, please join my mailing list.
I never bring that up.
I would like to get more people on my
mailing list because my space is really
dying. A slow, pitiful death. I barely
get any emails over there anymore.
And um, I don't know where, I
don't know where to go next. Um,
Coz I imagine Facebook will
take a nosedive. Twitter,
we'll take a nose dive and his whole
jumping around is driving me fucking nuts.
I figured out how to blog here on my
website and I'm going to start blogging,
actually began one about Sweden
that I will finish and um,
hopefully I'll get some
new videos up there,
but it's a billboard.com if you
could go on and you sign up,
you just sign up for my mailing list
underneath the city that you're closest to
and
okay.
Basically I only send you emails if I'm
coming to your town or if I'm going to
be on TV.
I'm not going to be one of
these douchebags who every
week gives you the bill
burr update and then I become spam in
your life. It's not going to be that way,
but please sign up for it because my days
on my space might be numbered because
I don't, I don't, I don't know
that there's anybody left.
I'm really feeling like fucking Mad Max
and I'm there looking for fuel. You know,
it's just whores and uh,
people sell in music.
That's all that's left and me, you know,
tumbleweeds over there. People. All right.
That's it. That's a podcast for this week.
Please tune in next week. Wait a second,
wait a second. Did you want to
chime in with something? Nia?
Well,
I'm just surprised you didn't talk about
Tila Tequila being shocked by that NFL
football player.
Oh, that's right. Shawne Merriman
choked out. Tila Tequila, you know I,
well Susan [inaudible]
she probably deserved it.
Exactly.
Fucking asshole.
What do you mean it's a podcast?
I got to make it funny.
Yeah.
I don't like how you actually have my,
you actually have my voice
down. Like you actually know
what I'm going to say. No,
that's not what I was going to say.
I was going to say before I was so
rudely interrupted with your completely
offensive, I don't like how you know,
you, have you noticed that with women,
whenever they do an impression of their
boyfriend, they always have to go,
Ooh,
before they say anything. I wanted to go
out to go to a restaurant and you know,
my boyfriend said he was going
to take me and I was like,
so we're going to go to the
restaurant and he's all right.
Football game.
Okay.
I know. My impression of you
is really bad. It is bad.
Do you want to go to a party this weekend?
My girlfriends
in a while ago.
What? Ben Roethlisberger Ah,
that was, that was, that was
us. That was a cash grab.
He raped me.
Ben Roethlisberger
well do you feel like, like the whole,
my whole big thing with the dogs.
Why don't you come over here near the
microphone if you're actually going to
come in here and high jacket is my lovely
girlfriend. Nia. Everybody. Hi. Hey.
Let me just do this as like an interview,
like a little Dick Cavett thing. What,
what was your question here?
Uh,
my question was in regards to
the football player who, uh,
allegedly choked out to what
Tequila, um, and, and other,
why you being so official?
The question that I had this afternoon.
And first of all, I just must say I love
the show and I'm really active listener.
First time caller. Uh, no, but
do you think, cause I feel like,
and I guess we'll see. Please
get to the point, ma'am.
We'll see how the story develops.
But like do you feel like the Michael
Vick thing got more attention then when
athletes have like sort of like these
abuse charges putting aside? Cool.
First of all,
Shawne Merriman didn't have like 40 my
space horse hung from trees that he was
electrocuted and drowning.
Okay.
He choked out one dumb whore with
a fake tits of bisexual hort. That,
and I have to say that I can,
I fucking hate the San Diego chargers,
but my hatred went down a
little bit knowing that he
slapped her on Tila Tequila.
It's just funny if she was, if
she was just, you know, a regular,
you know, Girl from Hooters
whose dad didn't stick around.
So she felt the need to dress
around scantily clad and
try to get guys attention.
You want to see my clam. If she was one
of those people, that's a woman say, Huh?
Do you think that's a woman's
say? Well, I'll tell you this.
I'll tell you this right
now and I might get an I.
Am I getting in trouble here as I
weighed into these dangerous waters?
Women don't say clam.
They don't refer to it as a clam.
So how would you know that? Because
I'm a woman. You asshole. Well,
well first of all, oh,
you're storming out.
You're going to take off your
little lapel mic and just walk out.
All right. Obviously I know they don't
do that. Get back here. You can't.
You can't just leave like
that. No, they don't say,
I'm going to show you my clamp,
but I will tell you this.
When women get fake tits,
they will show you them like they got
their nails done because obviously it was
a very insecure part of their body,
so now they have it and they will.
It's so easy to even be able
to touch them. Did you just,
all you gotta do is like what their big
paranoia is now that they have them,
they want you to tell
them that they feel real.
So all you gotta do is just
be like, uh, you know, other,
they look really natural at the,
do you feel like they feel oh yeah,
here and they just grab your hand for
some reason because their hand is on your
hand.
They don't feel like you're
actually feeling them up
before you felt a fake boob
before.
Okay.
Girl that I used to work with had um,
fake boobs and she was just
talking about it I guess.
Like sometimes they do and I was like, Oh
really? And she was like, yeah, feel them.
They felt, yeah, see where they
go. It's actually like nice.
I haven't really felt a lot of boobs.
Well when you say nice, what do they,
what do they felt like a bag of sand
both full and nice and just bucks to
me and soft, you know, like a woman
really. I came in here to
talk about, no, I'm actually,
I'm getting turned on by this. This is
like, well, this is really good. You know,
I gotta tell you got a lot
of creeps or listen to this.
So they probably touching themselves
right now. I know they drive trucks.
Help out a little. No, I'm not going to
haul out my girlfriend and my own podcast.
You're a good girl, right? Say it.
What do you, wait a minute. What are
you, this is what you do with the office.
You go around filling up girls
with fake tits. The office were,
where was it when you were at fucking
in a Bill Haley swimming pool down the
street.
I can never remember people's names.
What's the name of the fucking guy
who has playboy? Hector Camacho.
What's his name? Hugh
Hefner. I knew there was an h
nine I'm brutal one. That's one of
the on long. Hector Camacho was a box,
so that's one of the long standing jokes
in our relationship is how this is.
What happens is I can never remember
famous people's names. So I just,
whatever the first name that comes
to my mind or the names of movies,
like my boy, I called that movie the last
days of Dracula. What was the name of,
whoa. What was that movie
interview with the Vampire?
I called it the last days.
The last day is a Dracula.
That was a classic. We have a lot of fun
out here. Don't wait. Seals at the gym.
All right, well we're gonna wrap
up the podcast. Look up cute.
Cleo is over there with the ears
down. Yeah, she's a cutie. All right.
That's the it. That's it for the podcast.
She got a little bonus interview. Um,
and that's it. I want to thank, once
again. Everybody came out in Sweden.
I'm definitely going to come back.
They were always talking about bringing
me back there and everybody in Philly,
I run a new hour. I'm going to be
there. Please sign up for my, my, uh,
my website and a, yeah, if there's girls
out there was fake tits. I'm telling you,
you don't have to ask too many
questions and I'll find, you know,
there's actually a good chance they'll
take them out if you're in like a ground
round,
one of those kinds of restaurants where
in that restaurant where it was like,
I don't know how they
didn't shut down by the
health department with all those crushed
peanut shells on the floor. You know,
you walk into a barbershop,
they get a sweep up the hair.
How about you sweep up the peanuts?
You fucking disgusting cuts. All right.
Have a good week. I'll talk
to you later. Bye. Bye.
Yeah.
Okay.